what's up guys my name is vicerno you
know as time goes on
and i keep hearing myself say the churno
i'm like
what even is that welcome back to
another devlog monday
on a tuesday this week so i'm not doing
too bad now last week i know there were
no videos you guys are probably
wondering what i was up to
like no one cares i had a nice time in
the snow with my wife
and now we are back into another
lockdown here in melbourne
so fantastic what i have been working on
over the last
few days has been prefabs so prefabs are
an interesting topic because almost no
one knows what they are
unless they know what they are i mean
prefab what a word
so prefab technically stands for
prefabricated
something right i mean i know i think
the construction industry uses it it's
something that has been used in game
engines here and there throughout the
last
like 20 years or so basically what it
means is
some kind of entity or object that has
been pre-configured and is ready to go
the reason why prefabs are important for
a game engine is kind of difficult to
explain i think the best way to actually
explain it
is to think of a blueprint not like
unreal engines like
visual scripting blueprint system but
literally a blueprint you have a
blueprint for what an entity in the game
should be
and since you have that blueprint you
can now create
copies of this easily so to take this
into more of a real world example let's
just say that every time you shoot in
your game
you need to spawn some sort of rocket so
what is that rocket entity i mean it
might be like
an entity that physically has a mesh
attached to it because it's a rocket
maybe it's got a particle system on the
back which is kind of shooting that fire
out
it obviously has some kind of like
script attached to it that
gives it some kind of logic potentially
maybe there are lights on that rocket
and certainly one at the back for all of
the fire stuff maybe that rocket is
actually composed of
several rockets and it kind of splits
off like in the middle of its flying you
know this is getting kind of exciting so
the point is that it's not just some
simple thing we can just spawn out of
mid-air
it has to be like pretty much a scene if
you think about it like a scene of
multiple entities and a hierarchy and
components and all of this kind of
existing data that we then want to just
summon
at will and this doesn't just have to be
something that we kind of instantiate or
activate through our scripts
it can also be something that we use to
build up our level
so maybe we have certain objects in our
level like a tree
or i don't know something that we want
to have kind of multiple copies of
but we want them to kind of be all
linked to that same blueprint so that if
we were to change the blueprint because
we want to
change a part of that object then it
would update everywhere
because it's it's kind of all coming
from that that one place so hopefully i
have you convinced now that prefabs are
very important and a very useful feature
to have in a game engine i mean
if you think about it it's not strictly
necessary uh
in all of like the kind of demo games
that i've made in hazel so far
i've kind of gotten around this by just
writing kind of
uh entity creation code in my c-sharp
script
so it's like a good example is actually
i might just show a nice little example
so if i pop on into this uh
world which is basically i mean if i hit
play you'll see what this is it's just
kind of
uh looks like a normal game and then
whoa we get all of these blocks just
coming out of nowhere
so these are all obviously kind of
prefabs that have been instantiated
except they're not
what's actually happening in this
example and remember this is an example
of how to do this like without prefabs
is i literally have this like
underscore cube in the scene if we jump
to it it's actually kind of hidden
inside this thing and that is my entity
that has an actual like cube
mesh attached to it and then what my
c-sharp script does during runtime
is it finds this entity by its name and
then creates like
a copy of it but then changes a bunch of
parameters and that way we still kind of
have
a normal entity we can set up in our
scene as usual
but then when it comes time to accessing
that in the c
sharp script we have all of its
components like the mesh component ready
to go and we can just simply
create a new entity in the scene during
runtime and then steal
all of the stuff from this cube so that
of course is very far from ideal because
i mean yeah that works in this case we
just have
essentially a cube which is what like a
mesh component and like
i guess a transform that's it that's
really really easy to do and actually
what you don't see in this version is
the fact that there's like the c-sharp
script is also
adding like 2d physics components to it
like a rigid body
and a box collider that's also happening
through that c sharp script
obviously that's a little bit annoying
even though we can programmatically
build up an entirely new entity or
series of entities inside that c-sharp
script it's much easier to use the
editor for that
to be able to actually set up our prefab
which is an
entity or group of entities that has
all of the components set up
everything's set up perfectly using the
ui
using the actual editor so that we can
see what we're doing
and then create a prefab out of that
that we can then instantiate inside our
c-sharp scripts
or just use inside the engine so that in
essence is what a prefab is and why it's
useful now
let's dive in and take a look by the way
if you want access to this you can help
support hazel by going to patreon.com
there will be a link
in the description below and you'll get
access to everything you're seeing here
you can play around with it yourself
and of course you'll be helping to
support the development of hazel
so let's dive into scenes and i'll just
load up audio demo that's like a decent
scene so this scene and the reason i
loaded it up is because it's got a whole
bunch of entities in the scene hierarchy
and you can see we've also kind of got
parented entities here
and we're using some and some empty
entities here
as like a way to just organize the scene
a little better so this lighting
uh entity is actually a good example of
where it might be nice to make a prefab
so let's just say i like the lighting
environment that we have here i mean
under here we've got a directional light
with a certain color
and then we've also got a skylight a
dynamic skylight which is what you're
seeing here
so there's also a bunch of like point
lights in the scene but i'm not going to
worry about them too much so what i can
do
is create a prefab out of this lighting
entity so if i go to like a suitable
place such as
assets prefabs i can take this lighting
entity and just drag it into the content
browser like this
then i can give it a name such as
lighting and now i have this lighting
prefab
if i double click on it i'll be able to
kind of see an outline of what is
actually inside that prefab so if i look
over here
i have lighting i have directional light
skylight they actually pop up over here
for some reason i actually this is this
was not not intentional
i wrote this little thing it uses the
same kind of scene hierarchy
panel that is up here basically but in a
slightly different way
and they happen to just pop up in this
properties panel so i'll probably change
that because it's a little bit unclear
what is what
but you can see i can select these
entities here and
kind of look at them compared to what
i've got kind of in the scene
so that is my lighting prefab now what i
can do is go to like some other scene
such as uh let's look at uh test scene
what's test scene
okay this scene so if i go go into this
scene and i wanted that same lighting
set up let's go ahead and actually
delete the directional light the
skylight so we've got no lighting at all
if i go back to my prefabs i can just
drag in that lighting
and you can see that i've got the same
kind of lighting that i had
in the in the other scene but now in
this scene so that's a good example of
where
it's nice to use prefabs but obviously
this whole kind of setup that i've got
here
i don't have to just instantiate it by
just kind of dragging it in
to the editor and using it as part of a
kind of static scene like
the scene that i'm actually creating
within the editor i can take that a step
further and instantiate it from
a c script i've also got like this other
geometry
uh prefab which is like the geometry
that'll set up from the uh
other kind of audio test uh demo thing
so you can see that that's also an
example of uh you know
what we've got here which is uh you know
a bunch of decor
which is like these tauruses like this
floor which is actually a
separate kind of entity we've got all of
that stuff here so that's that's a good
example of what we can do with prefabs
again really simple to kind of create
them you just drag them here
give them a name and they're an asset
just like anything else in the engine
and you can actually instantiate them
now one thing that i have not done yet
which is kind of
important and this is again a work in
progress there is currently no way to
see what a prefab
is in your scene so usually like in
unity you'd see them as like
you know having a special icon and
they'd be blue and you can double click
on it and it'll kind of edit it in
isolation
nothing like that exists at the moment
and also they're not actually linked to
these files anymore so what happens at
the moment and i think i'll leave this
in as an option because
that way this acts more like a template
i guess but if i just drag
this in right you can see it just kind
of makes a copy of everything
and i've got it here in my scene right
but
if i change this actual asset or i edit
it somehow
i don't actually think it's possible to
edit this unless you actually like open
up the file and start changing things
manually
but if i were to edit this as as i will
be able to in the future
then you'll see that like this is not
going to update because this stuff
kind of it's it's the same as if i just
copied an entity from a different scene
and put it into this scene so under the
hood the way prefabs work is
they are essentially a scene they're a
scene because
if you think about it i mean a prefab is
is a scene right like you've got a
series of entities that
can have a hierarchy they don't have to
could just be a whole bunch of entities
and they need to be stored in some place
uh so
that's how they work under the hood but
anyway the point is there's still a bit
of work to do because there needs to be
a way
to kind of you know retain entities as
like um sorry retain prefabs
as some kind of special type of entity
that is actually linked to an asset that
if i modify the asset i can see that
because at the moment as i mentioned you
just drag this into the scene
and then they just get created and now
they're part of the scene
and they get serialized as part of the
scene as just normal entities as if you
had manually created them
so a little bit of work to do but that
is the general kind of gist
so i hope you guys enjoyed this little
devlog don't forget to hit the like
button if you did enjoy it let me know
what your thoughts are about this
prefab is pretty standard um not too
difficult to set up
i probably spent like less than eight
hours on this whole kind of system here
to be honest i think one of those hours
was spent on setting up an illustrator
file with that icon that you saw in the
content browser panel because up until
now i haven't actually been making any
of the icons myself
that's been uh done by some people on
the hazelcore team
and i didn't even have like a master
kind of file to work from so now we're
gonna
probably spend some time on the ui in
the future and standardize some of these
icons and stuff like that
but um yeah that was kind of my uh
journey now because i am sitting here in
a discord partner
that's on this side discord partner
hoodie
uh it's probably a good idea to mention
that i do actually have a discord
there'll be a link in the description
below
uh it's like the channel.com actually no
this i think someone made an actual
vanity url now so it's like discord dot
gg slash the cherno it's a fantastic
place for you no matter what it is
you're specifically interested in or
working on so it's a great community
where you can get help with like various
programming or game engine development
topics as well as just chat about like
what games you're currently playing what
you like it's also a great place to
discuss
these videos and these devlogs if you
don't really want to just leave a
comment below and probably never
hear from anyone again so definitely
check out my discord
the link will be in the description as i
mentioned and i will see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you